how do you deal with the unknown like
what it by recognizing I have no [ __ ]
choice
you gotta be up in the office whoever
will be before me talked about ownership
and leverage KPI detectors that out of
America music deliver this is not the
person Russia I love it
Your Honor if we asking the best media
analyst to analyze timber prices
Oh
what are you putting us people
I think is empowered I can maintain it
go into it how much travel I'm not
getting enough staying consistent
dude love legal process means that
you're intoxicated with the process it's
just that right like it's not being
intoxicated with wait a minute I pay
dirt how do I maintain it or grow it
more actually giving a [ __ ] about the
process and spank insist that is it I'm
going to give you a really good piece of
advice off this very short period of
time be binary about your decisions let
me tell you what I mean by that don't
overthink jumping into your first job
and then quit it the next day if it
doesn't feel like
[Music]
that's it there's nothing else that's it
don't overthink [ __ ] because you can
literally and you can literally impose
your thing into anything you just don't
know that thing you're jumping into but
it's not a end-all be-all the first
one's not right
nobody's going to give a [ __ ] if you've
got four companies on your resume first
two years no place you want to end up
yeah leaving college that's going to
happen for the rest your life like and
there's no different starting high
school and like picking college like
it's [ __ ] life yeah like nobody knows
what the [ __ ] gonna happen tomorrow so
how do you deal with the unknown like
when it by recognizing I have no [ __ ]
choice right
yeah like cuz that's actually life like
who does like zero people exist like you
have nope that's what my main thing is
like at every aspect yes you have to
think because I'm confident yeah like
I'm not scared because I know I can
handle anything you know and and I know
I can handle anything because I'm
grateful for everything I've got and I
never envy and want anything else and
I'm um you know driven by that and I'm
an optimist like if something bad
happens tomorrow I would default into
thinking well I'm so grateful that I've
had it for this long instead of like why
do they go away 100% and you need to
chip away at that and you need to
realize what's practical not this is an
insular game every time you let
somebody's voice get into your head and
their opinion or what they're doing
you'll become insecure every time you're
just about you with yourself and just
you you'll win confidence is only about
loving yourself what about the politics
is that raising the real but a funny
thing happens when you're not listening
if you you know you you can hear your
brothers points of view you can hear
your mom's points of view you can hear
your roommates points of view you can
hear my point of view but like when
you're actually not listening you're not
listening
I think everybody's trying to like
control [ __ ] that you can't control
I'm about to change open-door policy
enforce time with everybody because it's
my job your job is not or or or or
anybody you interact with to come to you
it's your job at how high of a
leadership you are it's your job to go
and figure out your vulnerabilities if
they exist or not it starts with me
everything is my fault I mean it's the
[ __ ] most of my life the [ __ ] meat
every single thing is my fault
I don't know stainer guys how we're
saying family let me come in here so I
get for saying hi this feel I'm so happy
to see you I'm good oh I feel better it
makes me happy
also if you say you do this thing where
I talk you may pretend to understand
everything okay I'm going to actually
you make a commitment be like I don't
get that or clear clarify the hood I by
the way took me a long time to be good
at that I used to be very much like yeah
I got it I hate that I've gotten so much
better in the last three or four years
cool
[Music]
[Music]